I was seeing a girl and and I came to
her house and I was like mm is that
fifty roses are that a hundred so she
goes it's a hundred I go hmm who said
that she goes it's just a guy's a friend
I go oh I see friends that's interesting
because it doesn't feel that way
then I called her and you know somebody
answers the phone but they don't somehow
the phone gets answered by accident we
mean well I don't know what I mean but I
just know that let's say I call I called
and the phone was answered so she might
have like seen it and she wasn't like
whatever she was coming screaming it off
whatever it is I just heard oh oh no I
heard this I heard this was the grass
tired are you see my shoes on shoes off
because I think under the bed oh that
was your girl oh my girl oh oh and girl
that's I called her up and I go I know I
went over and I go hey yeah yeah cuz I
don't for me if you like that guy that's
the truth I'm never gonna I'm not gonna
[ __ ] be like book you cuz if you
maybe like him maybe he's better we can
do you so I just thought I might go so
did you talk to her I find so did you
dude your guy get his shoes cuz I know
the run of the bed it's like and she's
just like I'm and it was a guy she had
dated yeah whatever I kept a cheat code
you can do if you're dating a girl or
you wanna know if she's seen other dudes
you go to the toilet man so you go to it
you lift the lid
it's very rare the girl to clean the lid
guys piss on that toilet oh you know
what the best thing is I've never done
that huh it was retile it Chuck dude I
love that you just told me that I wish
I'd known that I mean lift that [ __ ]
lid and see who else has been pissing in
my territory yep I'm like oh you know
you've been see no one lately no no no I
was pissed all over the lid ha girls not
doing that how come these pee on the
[ __ ] yeah that's interesting
I'm glad you told that it fellas
yeah there you go I'm gonna [ __ ]
check that out I will always lift the
lid now goddamn who else would do it
some dude with a big old angry dick yeah
who's that like I just got any busting
your girl who's handles your daddy yeah
that [ __ ] skinny 53 year old [ __ ]
guy with a with a bank account of this
dude this for my shoulders and I serve
and I'm in my 20s sir oh no I know
because I am body
I am body call just clothes because I am
body the hold on so how is this it's
about just kung fu kung fu' yeah you're
saying umph well that's how it's said so
I'm from I studied in China pistol